problema número 245 si x más igualada y
x
es igual a que es igual 2 por equis
porque bueno tenemos dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas vamos a sumar las tenemos
x más igualada y vamos a sumar x menos
igual a b me va a quedar x más x2 x
maciej -0 iguala a más y aquí puedo
despejar xx va a ser igual a b entre 2 y
ahora en lugar de sumar estas ecuaciones
las voy a restar va a ser x más igual a
menos x menos por menos es más más y
igual a menos b ahora hago esta
operación x x es cero y más y es igual a
2 iguala a menos b y aquí puedo despejar
y que va a ser igual a menos b entre 2
sólo me queda sustituir x y en esta
ecuación 2 por x que es a más de entre 2
ya que es menos de entre dos estados se
va con este me va a quedar un medio por
además ve por a menos b es igual a
cuadrada menos b cuadrado y esta es la
opción a siguiente problema problemas
246 un rectángulo tiene w centímetros de
ancho un perímetro de p centímetros y
una área de cada centímetros cuadrados
cuál de las siguientes ecuaciones es
verdadera
a esta gráfica voy a agregarle otra
variable que le voy a llamar h iba a ser
la altura bueno sabemos que el perímetro
de un rectángulo es igual a la suma de
sus lados en este caso aquí tengo que
este lado mide w y este mide h el
perímetro va a ser igual a 2 w más 2 h
pero ahora debemos tener la altura en
función del perímetro para luego
calcular el área así que vamos a
despejar la altura de esta ecuación
factor hizo el 2 y divido todo entre 2
me queda perímetro entre 2
es igual a doble o más h y como me
interesa tener la altura h va a ser
igual a perímetro entre 2 - w y ahora
esto lo voy a sustituir en la fórmula
del área el área k es igual a la base
por la altura w por la altura pero la
altura ya la tengo aquí es perímetro
entre 2 - w esto es por todo esto esto
es igual a perímetro por w entre 2 -
doble o al cuadrado multiplicamos todo
por 2 y nos va a quedar 2 k igual a p
por w menos 2 por w al cuadrado y como
estoy viendo las opciones tienen un
formato en el que está todo igual a cero
así que vamos a dejar todo del lado
derecho de la igualdad sumó 2 w al
cuadrado en ambos lados 2 w al cuadrado
+ 2 k menos
wv igual a cero y esta es mi opción el
siguiente problema problema número 247
en una secuencia aritmética es aquella
en la que cada término excepto el
primero es la suma del término anterior
más una constante la siguiente lista de
letras representa una secuencia
aritmética cuál de las siguientes
también es una secuencia de itm ética
tenemos nuestra lista de letras que es
pr st
y es una secuencia de métrica y aquí
están las opciones vamos a ver cada una
de ellas y nos vamos a imaginar este
como ejemplo de una secuencia genética 1
2 3 4 5 es una secuencia genética porque
cada término es igual a la anterior más
una constante en este caso es más 11 12
2 más 1 33 más 1 4415 ahora analicemos
este primer caso nos dicen que es 2 por
p 2 por el re 2 por ese 2 por 3 y 2 por
usemos este ejemplo 2 por 1 2 2 por 2 4
62 por 48 y 2 por 510 que como es tan
raras estoy haciendo pero bueno veamos
cuál es la diferencia entre 2 y 4 es 2
la diferencia entre 4 y 6 es 2 entre 6 y
8 también es 2 vemos que se cumple que
sigue siendo una secuencia aritmética
porque cada término es diferente del
anterior o por un valor constante este
sí es una secuencia aritmética veamos el
siguiente en la opción 2
bueno aquí se toma esta secuencia y a
cada elemento se le resta 3 lo estamos
desplazando tres unidades si yo tengo r
- 3 - p menos 3 para ver la diferencia
entre el ipe que me va a quedar bueno
r - 3 - p y menos por menos es más más 3
estos tres se van y me va a quedar que
esto es igual a r - p que es la misma
diferencia original de erp que tengo en
esta secuencia así que ésta también se
mantiene es una secuencia aritmética no
se modifica simplemente se desplazan por
igual vemos la tercera opción
r al cuadrado ese cuadrado etcétera todo
al cuadrado
tomemos de nuevo este primer ejemplo 1
al cuadrado es 1 2 al cuadrado es 4 3 al
cuadrado es 9 4 al cuadrado es 16 5 al
cuadrado es 25 cuál es ahora la
diferencia entre estos términos la
diferencia entre 1 y 4 son 3 entre 4 y 9
es 5 entre 9 y 16 son 7 entre 16 y 25
son 9 ahora sí estos números no son
constantes van siendo diferentes entre
cada término por lo que este no es una
secuencia aritmética este no es y la
opción en donde el 1 y el 2 es verdadero
y el 3 no se cumple es nuestra opción de
crisis es curioso estos cada uno de
estos números son cuadrados perfectos
estas diferencias no hay ninguna que sea
para las diferencias entre cuadrados
perfectos siempre va a ser un número en
paso nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo